so the question is why developing
countries Arab countries are not able to
make it on their own and what could be
the role of the Arab League into their
upgrading two to beam players in the
global economy for example through a
currency unit I would say that is a
complex question and the answer is
multifaceted so the first point I would
like to make is that there is no better
movement and now for developing country
for emerging markets to make so Manor
the Arab countries in Manor but also in
general emerging markets worldwide I've
never had this chance to become a
players in the global economy last
century was the century of Europe Japan
and the US this Center is definitely
this entry of the emerging markets and
there is a fantastic chance for emerging
market to make it Mina can make it as a
block so I would not definitely specify
a role for the Arab League in this
definitely can play a role but the main
role is to be played by individual
agents in individual countries namely
governments and private sectors so what
can the government do to improve the
situation in there are countries where
well they need to modernize their
country they need to cut bureaucracy
they need what do I mean by modernizing
cut bureaucracy stop subsidies to the
rich help their education sector to get
in touch with demand and supply Mickey
help the transfer of technology help
their country to get into the knowledge
economy and most of all help capital to
flow into the region so the mint meaner
and the GCC are as a regions are
countries that are exporting capital
because they don't have bond market so
governments for example they should
develop bond markets attract capital
because the needs are enormous from
infrastructure to education to health
etc so there is summarizing a role for
the government's then the private
sectors individual countries should try
to develop help their put their part in
the development of all this I said
before and try to look abroad try to get
some lessons learned from emerging
markets that made it before me and try
to import some lessons learned so as I
said government has a role to play
investments should go up both from the
private sector and from the public
sector the red tape should be cut
consumption should be stimulated so
menna can really become a block and the
consumption story the internal
consumption story can play going forward
the big role in the economic development
manner so domestic demand like
infrastructure
financial services from insurance to
life insurance to credit expansion of
credit to real estate development for
middle-class development
so many areas that would play the
consumption story manner to create
economic growth women so summarizing
there is never been a movement where
many can make it so well into the global
economy like this century is the center
of the emerging markets definitely the
Arab League can play a role but but i
would say in general if when i were to
look at its own history and build on it
Frank that is also its weaknesses I'm
fully aware that many has historical
legacies political issues and problems
but if you look at many more or less
there is some homogeneity in culture
there is imaginating languages and
homogeneity in religion and a history of
being able to live together amongst many
religions so if many were able to become
a block and and associate and again I go
back to the role of government break the
links break the trade barriers increase
trade links that would be a great
contribution for for men to become a
block and to play its role in this
center of the emerging market definitely
a currency union would help i would say
starting from the GCC is probably the
zone that is more harmonized from a
correspond to view of course there are
many issues to be sold at malaysian etc
but definitely if you don't have a
currency common courtesy is difficult to
create those liquid and deep capital
markets that can hold a bond market that
the mobile market was mentioning before
that is a requisite for the region to
keep it saving in itself and start
investing its own savings in
infrastructure etc etc so in one line I
believe that individual countries via
their governments by the private sector
should start and then Manish would
associate and become a block and take
advantage of this wonderful century for
emerging